the international media are closely
following the NSU trial beata shiva and
four others are being tried in
connection with the murders of 10 people
most of them of Turkish descent the
German public wants to know how the
neo-nazi terror cell could have remained
undiscovered for so long the country's
image has suffered can the trial repair
the damage I'm so the end of it should
demonstrate that we upholds the rule of
law that we stand by our Constitution
and that it serves as the basis of this
trial it should help improve Germany's
image tag on even it says a so long as
it's done properly and there are no
deals made then Germany will come out of
it looking better bet v dou shi sha
whiskas each side have the right wing
extremists NSU crimes harmed Germany's
image yes say sixty-six percent of
Germans thirty percent believe they have
not
some 3 million people in Germany have
Turkish roots public debate about the
issue of integration is ongoing what do
germans think of the relationship
between Germans and Turks living in
Germany there are no problem say eight
percent 51% believe there are a few
problems thirty percent see the
relationship as problematic we bother
submit the third generation is
problematic because somehow they've lost
their footing team builder in futility
and mostly mental I people need to be
taken seriously that's the main thing
but that's where people often make
mistakes we don't welcome immigrants who
come here we make them feel like
outsiders who are useless acidophilus
insight as investor good curtain
nevertheless the vast majority of
Germans are willing to live alongside
people with immigrant backgrounds
you